this has to be seen to be believed and
it's almost
as sad as it is unbelievable
donald trump has forced his way back
onto twitter he's tweeting
by writing letters which are then
published and retweeted by his kids and
friends
this is a former president folks you
might recall that donald trump was
banned from twitter
some time ago for constantly
persistently
endlessly stubbornly inciting violence
and telling
lies about the 2020 election results he
is now putting out statements
through his save america pac which are
often duplicates from things he's
posting to
gab some kind of right-wing social
network
and it's all on donald trump letterhead
but these are now tweets he is he is
publishing letters that are just tweets
yesterday trump put one out that says
statement by donald j
trump 45th president of the united
states wouldn't it be fantastic if the
legendary herschel walker ran for the
united states senate in georgia
he would be unstoppable just like he was
when he played for the georgia bulldogs
and in the nfl he is also a great person
run
herschel run that's a tweet
in written letter form he figured out
how to force his way back onto twitter i
believe this is a ban
evasion but we'll talk about that and
then donald trump jr
reposts it and before you know it
trump's tweeting
writing tweet length letters posted by
his family
to twitter he then sends a much
crazier one and this is i almost
feel bad for the guy this is one of the
saddest
statements i've ever seen from a
president trump clearly triggered by
yesterday's announcement from joe biden
that the u.s has secured an additional
hundred million doses of the jnj vaccine
uh donald trump quote tweeting sort of
writing a letter where he says
this is it's almost sad quote
i hope everyone remembers when they're
getting the kovid 19
often referred to as the china virus
vaccine
that if i wasn't president you wouldn't
be getting that beautiful shot
for five years at best and probably
wouldn't be getting it at all
i hope everyone remembers isn't there
something
really sad about that these really are
tweets now i don't you know what can
twitter really do
can twitter ban statements written
statements from the former president no
i don't think so i don't even think that
they should but
if we're honest this does violate the
spirit of the ban i mean it is ban
evasion and it's all so
strange and desperate and i know that
some are saying
nobody should even mention that trump is
doing this you're amplifying it by
sharing it
this isn't about amplifying the content
this is about
how donald trump has figured out a way
in his desperation to be back on twitter
he's figured out a way to circumvent the
van the ban
it's about desperation it's about tech
regulation
it's about so many other things that
we've been talking about on this show
but some aspect of this is also just
really
really sad i imagine trump sitting there
at mar-a-lago
eating his kfc and drinking his diets
and his malts as he likes to drink
um and watching joe biden show up with
as we saw yesterday the jnj ceo
and the merc ceo and announcing
everybody's going to be able to get a
vaccine by the end of we're going to
have enough vaccines for everybody by
the end of may not necessarily everyone
will get one by then it's going to take
some time to inject them
we're doing a hundred a million dose
deal
we may have so many doses we're going to
be giving them to other countries and
trump wants to tweet
but he's off twitter so this is what he
is now doing
it's both delusional but also a little
bit sad in some way
i'm not gonna shed any tears though if
that's what you're waiting for that's
the latest from trump
forcing his way de facto back on twitter
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control
of your finances you can create up to 12
of these virtual credit cards a month
you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free and
like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman